[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she's the size of one of my size it's
the group B kickoff and things are more
dangerous than ever
and do we have a politician campaigning
for a win this may be a candidate who
ran for president
this is unmasking the masked singer
things certainly were dangerous during
the first group be dangerous and the
clues got a lot harder so much harder
Charlie and I have done our best we have
dug through all the clues and evidence
and we will get to that but first take a
look at tonight's heartbreaking
elimination
[Applause]
[Applause]
truly an icon a legendary skateboard
like they said and one of the last
people I would expect for them to get to
do this out truly so difficult like I
went through so many names before I
finally got to could this be Tony Hawk I
mean did you think it was him what led
you to feel that way there were a few
clues that point it to someone who
wasn't from performing or singing
definitely yeah I don't think I ever
pinpointed it directly to be Tony Hawk
okay I did we were in the newsroom doing
a little dishing let's get right into it
and dissect some of these clues tonight
so right off the bat let's take a look
at this costume that we're seeing there
can we pull up that elephant costume one
more time you can't well I guess okay so
this is someone who's very tall yes hole
slender when he was standing next to
Nick Cannon you know that that's
obviously like a pretty good indicator
that this person is well over six feet
tall so I was like Tony Hawk definitely
six foot three he fits the bill there my
other big tip was that bicycle poster so
when when we saw the clue package and he
was rolling through the town and there
was a poster of the bicycle kind of
cemented up on the wall it was the dis
re Tony actually designs a line of BMX
bikes so you would think oh like Nicole
threw out Lance Armstrong lamps Johnny
Lance
yes so you would think it was like a red
herring but if you do a little bit of
research you'll know Tony actually has
you know some work in the BMX arena and
another one that took a little bit of
realizing it's not as obvious were the
Blue Jays so Tony's company is actually
called bird house but obviously they
weren't going to give us a hawk like his
last name in the clue package right but
a bird blue day still playing it's all
there it's all there what other ones did
you have for him the other one was the
Christians art supply poster that we saw
not poster kind of sign up on on the
wall there so this is kind of a stretch
but this is what I found
Christian Slater the actor he
interviewed Tony for hero magazine in
2016 and Tony revealed that he's the
first person to ever skateboard in the
White House which kind of piggybacks on
another clue Tony said that he sorry the
the elephant said he paraded through
White House's so both of those things
like the Christian the why
house I was like I feel like there's
enough here to be totally cockeyed sure
enough sure enough it was and one more
that I pointed out we heard him saying
the clue package canvassing park benches
and we saw them kind of doing jumps and
tricks off various park benches in the
clue package yes obviously alluding to
skateboarding tricks that you would do
on a sidewalk or a bench or jumping off
something precisely so as we're going
through you know who we think who we
think we're of course listening to who
the judges think and in our weekly
segment called reality check you guys
know we love to give a little friendly
dose of reality to the wackiest perhaps
guess of the week and of course shocker
it goes to ken Jeong take a listen we're
talking about white house as a clue this
may be a candidate who ran for president
who recently dropped out of running for
the White House
hear me out better work plays bass and
drums in a punk band and he's better
work has a cure for America and I love
that song choice so better work I
nominate you Jenny just shaking her head
in disapproval correctly Robin straight
up just like no no no I can like
absolutely not I would love to see a
politician do this show look politicians
are now doing Dancing with the Stars why
not try the mask seriously I'll sing for
us yes well we do have five contestants
left so this is who we'll be seeing for
the rest of the night as well as next
week but on top of that we asked you
guys on Twitter who you were most
excited for tonight in the performance
and it leads with the Frog and the taco
the elephant was still pretty pretty
high up there sadly he is gone if we
will not be seeing more of him but our
first performer certainly gave us an
unforgettable performance take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so right off the bat let's just
establish this is the hardest group of
clues that we've had to dissect yet yes
so this was really challenging this is
obviously someone who can sing can
certainly dance and my best guess for
this one is gonna be Bow Wow what do you
think online I was looking on Twitter
while the show was airing and people
were very very adamant on it being Baba
as well what image is solidified it for
you okay so a couple of things let's
start with the clue package so we saw a
doggie bag some leftovers so I was like
is it like are those doughnut holes I
was like getting a little too deep with
it and and quite literally that's a
doggy bag which is the name of bow-wows
second album of course the name relates
back Wow Wow
okay you got it all the dog buns are
there we also saw the Atlanta Olympics
poster so again they're trying to I
think make us think it could be an
athlete or someone maybe who performed
at the Atlanta Olympics well bow-wow is
actually from Ohio but if you know him
and you're a fan of his career he has
championed Atlanta very very much so I
mean he he's mentored by Jermaine Dupri
who is practically synonymous with
Atlanta and he's also on the show
growing up hip hop Atlanta so he's
definitely got strong Atlanta ties the
other big clue was the radio mic with
some dollar bills we saw a 100 a five
and a six add all that up you get 106
Bow Wow was a former co-host on 106 &
Park so this this feels like Bow Wow the
only thing that threw me was I I didn't
think that that vocal tone was someone
of his age I thought it sounded mature
and I thought could it possibly be
someone like the guys from boys to men
yeah obviously wanye was amazing on
Dancing with the Stars and knows how to
be a performer on reality TV but my
hunch is telling me about well what do
you think I'm with you on all the bells
are you okay go ahead said it you said I
have to point out though Nicole did say
one thing here she said I know who it is
I know exactly who it is but she
couldn't pinpoint who it was and then
she said
raid a I'm not getting rave I hear no
especially raging has such a distinct
tone to his voice I feel like every time
he comes on the radio you immediately
know it's him
this was someone I really didn't quite
recognize it took me dissecting a clue
package kind of work backwards yeah well
our next performer gave us a perfect
song choice check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I'm going Sabrina carpenter
first of all a plus song choice yes I am
with you on Sabrina carpenter okay so a
lot of people on social media are
thinking it's someone from fifth harmony
or possibly even ariana grande herself
which that wouldn't be very fun what it
looks like yeah it's definitely not
ariana grande let's go back to Sabrina
carpenter she's an actress she's a
singer I think it's pretty hilarious
that Jenny said she's the size of one of
my thighs so that immediately right
there a physical clue universe
yes Sabrina carpenter is only five feet
tall so definitely like size
proportionally this this makes all the
sense in the world then in the clue
package we saw these binoculars so it
was almost like a theater vibe it kind
of gave me like oh this is someone who
likes to be on stage who likes to
perform while it was just recently
announced that Sabrina is about to star
in Mean Girls on Broadway
yeah and that looks like a Broadway
theater to me if I'm sure yep and
continuing with the performing we
actually saw some pirates fighting yes
yes
Sabrina actually played Wendy in a live
production of Peter Pan and Tinkerbell a
pirate Christmas so she has worked with
pirates before yes she has yes I also
want to talk about something we heard
during the clue package the the kitty
said people don't think of me as the
person I have become but the person I
once was now today Sabrina is 20 but we
really kind of first met her when she
was 13 when she was freshly cast on the
show Girl Meets World and she's really
grown up a lot if you're a fan of her
music she's mature now she's
sophisticated she's even a little sexy
take a look at the performance tonight I
mean that's a burlesque kitty doing very
sexy dance moves and really kind of
owning her confidence and I feel like
this is Sabrina's year and I feel like
her music career is gonna explode and
this was a perfect show to introduce
herself like maybe to people who aren't
that young and maybe don't know her as
well yeah it's a burlesque Kitty that is
something you can only hear us say on
the master
there was one more clue though I believe
we have it it's a shattering rose we
didn't exactly find anything about this
I thought at one point it could have
been a red herring towards someone maybe
from the bachelor/bachelorette I don't
think we're getting that anymore but if
you know what this does
me and let us know you know what I like
to believe this to be in omage to seal
who sings kiss from a rose a real chance
another season she's still going for CL
talking about Celia well the taco
certainly flew us to the moon with his
performance take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
straightaway Tom Bergeron host of
Dancing with the Stars the clue package
I watch I kind of digest but the second
I saw the taco starts singing you can
just tell there's that tone that little
vocal inflection that we're so used to
hearing Tom every week when Dancing with
the Stars is on he's like a friend to us
like he comes into our living rooms and
I feel like I know him even though I
don't know him personally I think we
heard him saying in the coop act aids
he's a comforting part of our lives and
has been decades and that's why we
recognize this voice right away 100% now
we did a little digging on Twitter can
we throw up the photo of Tom hanging out
with his taco apron on yes I mean do we
need more proof than this the guy is a
bonafide taco fan and here is actual
photo evidence of it and if that wasn't
enough when we saw a VHS tapes in the
clue package I believe that is obviously
throwing a nod to America's Funniest
Home Videos again somewhere you would
recognize his voice hearing it every
night from watching that 100% and then
we also saw an anchor kind of situated
on top of a plate there in the kitchen
again I think they're trying to make us
think is this someone who has a nautical
tie or they a sailor in their spare time
no I think quite literally tom is the
anchor of Dancing with the Stars and
America's Funniest Home Videos and he
has incurred one more thing as well we
saw a Rubik's Cube this one may be a
stretch but I'm sticking with it no I
like it
okay Tom host at the revival of
Hollywood Squares those are literal
squares yes and that looks like the
layout but the set would look like as
well exactly
finally this is some deep evidence you
guys that I have acquired since becoming
a true Los Angeles resident in the clue
package we see the taco running through
a parking lot yeah here he is sprinting
through a parking lot you guys that is
literally the parking lot at the CBS lot
here in Los Angeles those those
apartment complexes have an arrow on
that eye at the bottom of it that I used
to go to all the time so as I saw this
it's like this is where Dancing with the
Stars is filmed they lit the masked
singer crew literally brought their
cameras to Tom's place of work and there
he is sprinting out of the office tacos
there was one clue though that online
you guys were saying it could be
sweating towards someone else we saw a
San Francisco trolley there it is and a
lot of
people on Twitter we're saying it could
be Bob Saget nope red herring I'm
calling it right now they want us to
think it's like a full house
nod or something like that this vocal
tone it is gonna be really hard to argue
with me that it's anyone other than Tom
Bergeron and Nicole made a great guest I
just have to point it out here she said
I think it's Jesus because his voice was
just so good you get you got it in a
college you know whatever you think
girls are the vocal expert yes exactly
well our next performer certainly gave
us all the chatter and more check it out
[Music]
legends only on the massacre the masked
singer is reaching truly for icon we
unfortunately said goodbye to Chaka Khan
last way too early way too early but I'm
gonna go ahead and say this is another
legend Dionne Warwick you and Robin both
agreed on this one yeah Robin got it and
and then I started to work again work a
little backwards and a lot of things
were pointing towards miss Dionne so
let's let's cue up the clue package here
we saw kind of like a football I'm sorry
I'm no sports expert a football play
written on a whiteboard so it says bang
bang formation actually Dionne recorded
a version of the song mr. Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang for the James Bond film Thunderball
I'll take that yeah continuing with the
football theme here we saw two people
one with a 19 and one with a 79 on their
football jerseys obviously we would
immediately think 1979 right someone for
you what is the significance well Deion
is currently 79 years old and she
actually began her career in singing at
the age 19 I mean a queen to be 79 years
old and still singing crushing it like
truly like these vocals it was it was
just so like the hair on my arm raises
because she's just such a living legend
and we are blessed to have her on the
mouth singer if it is her the last clue
that I want to point out are these gold
pom-poms so at first I was thinking oh
it's probably someone who either loves
gold jewellery or has a lot of gold
records or a lot of Grammys but quite
literally Dionne sang the theme song for
the 1980 variety show called solid gold
gold so there's lots of gold lots of
gold everywhere and like we said Robin
throughout gone steam and Nicole
actually said Darlene love who is
another legend one may see eventually on
the show and we threw her name out last
year and we thought she was possibly the
Christmas tree yes so very exciting
stuff well next up I think we're getting
a call do you drive what wait I I think
she's calling me as well who's that I
think it's the banana well our next
performance is certainly appealing check
Oh
[Music]
occupation centers
we said the clues we're getting harder
and this is the true stumper is it is it
too premature to reality check ourselves
yeah forever
whatever we're about to say we will
regret you know it's it's too early in
this group for us to throw out a true
name or to attach a name we have a lot
of theories or guesses but there's not
someone that I feel confident enough in
this information and in their pack
insight in their performance too
attached to a name so I don't know you
want to kick us off here we saw a few
clues that were obviously supposed to be
pointed out so we saw a cowboy hat at
the start of the clue package people
online we're thinking maybe someone of
the country genre really here country
and the voice now we also saw a Blowfish
it was literally a Blowfish yeah very
exotic and we also saw a blue collar so
that's another big one that they made
sure to point out sure you know some of
the guesses that we have here are Bill
Engvall who is formerly part of the
hugely successful Blue Collar Comedy
Tour the banana also made a reference to
his daughter is part of the reason why
he chose the banana as his costume and
Bill Engvall does have a daughter
he was also under with the stars in this
show as the same casting director as
Dancing with the Stars so I don't know
let us know we're struggling here with a
banana we are super duper struggling
another exciting week more to come we
will be here next Wednesday recapping
the wait kickoffs then we have semi
finals we'll be back for the semi finals
next week as we say goodbye to another
mass singing celebrity I'm Deidre Behar
I'm Charlie O'Keeffe we'll see you next
time bye guys getting another call
[Music]